Bill O'Reilly remains defiant despite
losing his job at Fox News over sexual
harassment scandal the biggest star of
cable news was forced out yesterday from
his top-rated show he was a prime-time
fixture for more than 20 years O'Reilly
said in a statement quoted is
tremendously disheartening that we part
ways due to completely unfounded claims
but that is the unfortunate reality many
of us in the public eye must live with
today Anna Werner is at Fox News
headquarters in New York and a good
morning good morning bill o'reilly
continued to draw huge audiences even as
this scandal enveloped him but after
more than 50 advertisers fled fox news
channel again was confronted with the
question of whether its corporate
culture is hostile to women so on
wednesday the network's parent company
said after a thorough and careful review
of the allegations Bill O'Reilly will
not be returning to Fox News Channel it
is the end of an era here at the Fox
News Channel on Wednesday night bill
o'reilly named vanished from his show
bill has been the undisputed king of
cable news and for good reason hi I'm
Bill O'Reilly thanks for watching us
tonight he had spent 16 years at the top
of the cable news heap but then word of
quiet settlements with five women came
out in the New York Times sexual
harassment claims go back to 2004 and
fox news came under intense pressure to
drop him NPR media correspondent David
folkenflik says the situation became
untenable for the family that controls
Fox at a certain point what the Murdochs
had to decide was whether they wanted
this issue of sexual misconduct to
define their network Rupert Murdoch
along with his sons Lachlan and James
told employees we want to underscore our
consistent commitment to fostering a
work environment built on the values of
trust and respect O'Reilly ouster was
announced while he was on vacation a
photo yesterday showed him at the
Vatican shaking hands with the Pope in a
statement O'Reilly called the
allegations unfounded and said I will
always look back on my time at Fox with
great pride in the unprecedented success
we achieved
Fox News founding chairman Roger Ailes
resigned after similar accusations this
is a tough decision for me because one
of his accusers Fox News star megyn
kelly left the network in January she
was reportedly angered by comment so
Riley made on CBS this morning about her
claims in November I'm not interested in
basically litigating something that is
finished that makes my network look bad
radio host Wendy Walsh Ulmer o'reilly
factor' gastric came forward this month
to say she too was a victim of
O'Reilly's advances describes Fox News
internal culture this way they are
trapped in a former time in another era
in a time when women were beautiful
ornaments in workplaces who got coffee
and typed now yesterday another of Roger
Ailes his accusers gretchen carlson sent
out this tweet she said the only way to
end harassment is to shine a light on it
no more silencing women O'Reilly book
publisher Henry Holt says its plans have
not changed Gayle all right Anna thank
you very much